let's go next to
oh i don't know why don't we go to frank
from jersey frank you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
hey how are you doing today good and
please please please turn off discord
notifications because we're every time
that blings it's coming through
i'm sorry i have the uh i have do not
disturb on so i'm not sure why is there
something else that i should have said
on yeah in your settings notifications
just turn all of those damn
notifications off settings notifications
and then we'll stop uh hearing that and
it'll be beautiful
okay how's that
all right let's what was on your mind
today i don't know if it worked but
let's see
no it did not work
give me your question and we'll take the
answer offline
okay i'm sorry so um basically uh i'll
just start with the the first one uh
right now i'm having a little bit of a
family issue where
um
my parents were originally very you know
logical with their decisions regarding
kovid and being safe and you know
actually wearing their mask and
everything um but now unfortunately it's
kind of gotten to a point where
i mean uh
you know he even showed up yesterday
with like a cloth mask and it was just
something from like the doctor's office
with like an insurance name on it
and uh you know this is somebody who
does understand n95 and things like that
they're not vaccinated um
they just keep kind of getting more and
more crazy conspiracies off the internet
i'm kind of finding it hard to uh you
know even using some of your advice in
earlier streams that i've watched of
yours to combat conspiracy theorists
finding it really really hard to talk to
them um
with a lot of the kind of like you keep
putting it lately very very weaponized
information um what's the conspiracy
theory well give me give me a what's a
conspiracy theory that they believe
right now
i mean uh
i'm almost embarrassed to say them to be
honest but like
uh just given ideas like recently new
year's i really wanted to see them and
uh instead he was telling me that
because me and the woman i live with is
vaccinated
the vaccine is going to spread covet to
them and uh we're the ones that is
actually going to cause it through the
spike proteins and like eight thousand
other you know yeah
that's one of the craziest ones that's
like the woman who said she was
experiencing rectal bleeding when she
went near vaccinated people i mean that
i don't that's that's a pretty deep hole
you got to dig your way out of you know
i don't know and if and you're saying
that the casual socratic method of
questioning doesn't work with them
i have tried almost every logical type
of like you know reasoning even even for
example they're slightly religious i'm
not into it but you know they for some
reason believe that this is something
that is like an opinion thing and not
fact or science based yeah and uh that's
what i think is
i can't crack this wall and uh
unfortunately my mother just goes based
off of whatever my father finds and he's
just stuck on the internet for eight or
ten hours a day on you know rumble and
[ __ ] shoot and all this other guards oh
my god so listen it sounds like you've
tried a lot of things i think as a
last-ditch effort before considering you
know to what degree you want to continue
engaging in this stuff
would be
try to go with a very common um
sort of psychoanalytic question
which is what would it mean for you if
this belief weren't true if you were
wrong about this because sometimes if
you can't pierce with the socratic
questions like how did you come to
believe this sometimes people have a lot
of emotion and psychology and meaning
tied up in their beliefs and it's the
last ditch i don't know that it's gonna
do too much but but i might say
what what would it mean to you if it
weren't true that walking around near
vaccinated people did any of this stuff
and the vaccines actually work like what
would that mean to you and see what
happens that's my only other idea
that's actually a really interesting
perspective i appreciate that because i
know it's a hard kind of
thing to just throw at you but listen uh
i know i already took up a lot of time i
really appreciate all the work that you
do and uh you know you really put out a
great article every every day so thank
you very much all right thanks frank
from jersey and learn from frank guys
turn off all notifications all
notifications and try not to use speaker
we we can do this folks i know we can do
this
uh but we've got to all work together
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 percent plastic
free made without any virgin tree fibers
meaning no new trees are cut down but
real paper is super soft and durable you
don't have to sacrifice quality to help
the planet these are great products from
a usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable plastic free packaging
everybody needs paper towels and toilet
paper buy ones that you will feel good
about and they're giving my audience 30
office subscription when you go to
realpaper.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below